we are going to take cg characters and
we are going to generate photo real
versions of them using ai
so join us as we play a little show and
tell a little guessing game as to who is
this strange looking human being and who
do they represent
all right so we are going to do a pretty
cool thing here we are going to take cg
characters cartoon characters and we are
going to generate photo real versions of
them using ai if you ever wondered what
a famous video game character might look
like if they're a real human being well
this ai will give you that result and
it's really easy to use you can run it
in your browser so you might remember we
made a video to see if ai could age us
up or down correctly the beginning
process of that is you had to take a
picture and you had to convert it into a
latent space latent spaces they're a
little hard to describe but if you
imagine like in a video game you're a
character creator we have sliders and
you can like change the expression or
the width of the head that's basically
what the ai has it has like a lot of
those sliders it has like thousands if
not millions of attributes of a face
it's drawing from a data set of actual
human features so when it creates the
latent space version it goes okay he's
got a really sharp nose i gotta find
what the actual like human equivalent of
a sharp nose is that's why i think it's
really interesting like you said you
have to draw the actual final piece from
real faces so if your face is so
distorted or so devoid of detail that
they look nothing like what real humans
knows our eyes look like you will
probably end up with a very weird result
so you guys uh shout me out a character
that you would want to see
duke nukem i'm an equal opportunity ass
kicker he's got sunglasses on so we'll
see what happens
[Laughter]
let's do another one mr incredible mr
incredible request claim on claim
numbers
all right that's a big chance
oh image path okay so what happened here
it's not finding the facial landmarks
the mouth is lacking like defining
landmarks of what the ai uses to find
lips on a human face
what about woody from toy story woody
from five story
there you have it
i mean
yeah it's probably kind of accurate
that's a photo real woody
hey let's do uh geralt from the witcher
all right it's already kind of like
realistic you know all right geralt.jpg
[Music]
like once again it has to pull from real
people most of the people with white
hair are old people so that's why geralt
looks freaking old his left eye is just
going off to the side
yeah he's old yeah he's just old yeah so
would you guys all like to make your own
real people of famous characters
which ones i'm going to choose let's all
pick like four or five characters and
then at the end we'll go to the tv
everybody shows their real version and
we have to guess who it is i got some uh
crispy ideas in mine here
off to the races let's go
i'm gonna do a shrimp they say shrimps
don't have human-like features but
i disagree
this is my first one
i think i'm going to stick with pixar i
want like really fun ones for people to
guess
that are like
cool
i'm doing a mix of
my favorite
video game characters as well as my
favorite animated movie characters i'm
trying to fool these guys i don't want
anybody to guess mine
i think i'm going to do all video game
characters here i was thinking joel from
the last of us seen as the new last of
us shows coming up with pedro pascal i'm
gonna go link here legend of zelda and
then uh try a few more here as well i'm
gonna do
i wanna do commander shepard for mass
effect i wanna do some metal gear solid
characters i don't know i'm i need to
find a few more faces i'm not totally
sure yet like what's the last game i
played
[Music]
oh yeah just picking some really wonky
ones and trying to get them to read so
it's just like who the heck is that and
show them the original they're like
doesn't make sense
i also just like take really iconic
characters that are kind of distorted
from video games
and see what happens when like you turn
that to a real person so i am doing an
interesting mix of characters here i
want to do
a couple that are super cartoony and
like really weird a couple pieces of
historical art
you could say i'm a fan of shrimp shrimp
is not pretentious it's not fancy it's
the every man's decapod crustacean i
know nico said this ai has limitations
in that shrimps aren't human-like but i
find them very human like i find them
very expressive so i'm bringing this
this red boy into photoshop
and i'm gonna just do some contrast
adjustments to hopefully fool the ai
into thinking that it's a human face
shrimp human hybrids i think we're close
once elon's done going to mars i think
that'll be the next thing he tackles
it actually worked like it's crazy this
thing is amazing
so norman reedus is in death stranding
so i took the character in death
stranding and turned it into just back
into norman reedus what other real
uh characters were based off
even spacey and metal modern warfare i
don't understand this stuff i have zero
pictures
it's fun i'm just knocking them out now
look at this
some of the ones i was really excited
about ended up uh
not working because the program just
couldn't
find the facial landmarks none of my
shrimps worked i'm actually very
disappointed with this just frankly
ridiculous that ai hasn't caught up to
include shrimps it's not very inclusive
fix your let me manually input the face
landmarks
shrimp inclusion
i still got some really interesting
surprises some good some
maybe a little more funny than good
[Music]
all right
i want to see your guys creations so
join us in front of the television
as we play a little show and tell a
little guessing game as to who is this
strange looking human being and who do
they represent
i have quite the spread of options to
choose from
the mechs are finally here and i know
that the guys are recreating video game
characters in real life but guess what
we got real video game characters in a
real video game courtesy of today's
sponsor macarena macarena is a new
third-person shooter built from the
ground up to promote friendly mobile
play it's free to play has multiple
fast-paced game modes and focuses on
short high-intensity team pvp play and
if there's one thing i love about
mecharina it's doing the mecharina while
i'm doing the macarena so let's get
started and open this up they sent us a
mystery box hey macarena they gave us
this little ooh ooh it's got a little
mech in there hey macarena we've got max
on mex on max ah look at that mac in mec
arena you take control of your own mech
to run and gun your way through five on
five team mech battles your mechs are
the real stars of the show and there's a
ton of them to unlock and upgrade each
one has a unique combat ability and can
be customized with a ton of different
upgrades and weapons kind of scan this
qr code macarena dot live oh it's gonna
pop up uploading oh god you're in there
oh god i'm in there a macarena macarena
macarena a macarena macarena
a
macarena now the greatest thing about
macarena is that no matter what your
play style is you can get in on the
action right now they have awesome
in-game events and a great login rewards
program arena is completely free to play
on ios and android and you can use the
link in the description below or scan
the qr code right here and get one black
carbon skin 300 acorns 50 000 credits
and more to help kick-start your game so
that's it just click the link in the
description below or use the qr code get
started with all that free loot and
we'll see you in there
all right guys you ready are we
everybody close your eyes
look away
[Music]
all right good luck
george washington it's abraham lincoln
it's just george washington
that's what he looked like i guess
[Music]
oh wait who's this
all right now the funny thing is that
guy is consistent
[Music]
next one
[Music]
it's like bollywood snakes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
ten actors you never realized were in
front of you your whole life
[Music]
oh
that's the heavy yeah i like that a lot
this is the one where i feel like it's
making it better yeah all right sam i
wanna see what you've got
[Music]
the bad guy from far cry yeah
yes is that boss
there you go you got it all right i'm
gonna go to the next one look away
oh alex vance yeah obviously i thought
this one was actually a pretty faithful
representation
you know
it's really good that's what you would
cast in the house
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
his name is normal reedus
[Laughter]
all right all right
[Music]
see this is not it's not kevin's this is
definitely not well it's the character
he played
i know what you want
[Music]
doom who's that
oh i know
honor
yes there you go
you can't say keanu reeves because it's
i did not use the photo of keanu reeves
i used
a render of johnny silverhand
it didn't look like keanu reeves at
first when you put it side by side it's
like oh it's keon reed it's just like
slightly more manly and rugged
oh wait there's a guy from it's the
witcher guy girl is that gerald is that
another
geraldo this is like the 1991 like some
guy in england is like yo we're doing
this
and like it's a cult it's a cult hit yes
dude
no no no
i thought you just ran that one through
cloud yeah what's that next cloud from
smash from smash brothers
yeah
it looks like a female cloud though yeah
this one is kind of intense
boom with that
dude john denver
oh french or what's his name dutch or
french or the guy who's like the sas
dude yeah right i wasn't too happy with
this one either jordan come on up i have
two i got two to work
who is this guy elmo
what's his name the kid from coco
uh i don't know i don't know his name
though miguel or something
that one actually is really good but he
looks like an old woman
[Music]
oh
cinderella
cinderella oh yeah
yeah but it actually kind of looks like
you know that really looks like a
cosplay where they ran out of time to do
a wig
all right that's my two guys
let's do griffin
[Music]
oh i'm not gonna lie you might not get
this one oh it's the new dude that leo
is the hr movie that just came out here
he's like
chase just nails it on the first guess
luca was a great movie i actually liked
that
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's just this woman posing for a
driver's license photo
it's really interesting that for a lot
of like the more cartoony like pixar
style characters it ended up giving the
render like the rendered person more
feminine features
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this one's a deep cut this one's a d
wait is is that freaking caesar i feel
like that's a it's like a marble bust he
has a warm no
wait is it a lizard all right this one
was i wanted to see what it would do
with a sumerian sculpture so they
actually turned it into a sumerian man
like
it's it's like there you go
of course captain america uh the
computer did something real weird with
it i don't know how it got it
[Laughter]
why are you like this why yeah why are
you like this christian europe
all right everybody look
this is a special homage to uh something
we know
that's not me
[Music]
that one looks pretty good yeah wow that
looks like a really creepy instagram
picture
[Music]
oh
is it the whole
it looks like a like a zombie character
the job of the hut no is it my dad i
knew they wouldn't get it see i'm going
to stump him
how did that work i have no idea what
how did that hurt like we were trying
much more human-like faces than that and
it would not not work
that's the kid from up no no no no
no
no
[Music]
not
am i the only real man left all right
fenner you're up
[Music]
oh oh that's van gogh
yeah
it's like he took he was in a hot tub
for like a few hours
[Music]
this one here one of my favorites is
this a meme that's a statue isn't it
yeah it's a statue oh this is that that
horribly cast statue that has been
turned into a moment
oh that's link yeah wow those are some
wonky eyeballs dude that's really cool
cool yeah that one works really well but
link looks like a lot like a girl
this is my masterpiece is it the statue
of liberty yeah it is
from that
you can just see the hat up above
whatever the hell that thing's on her
head
this one here this is my favorite that's
definitely from a painting dutch one
with the the woman with the white wait
is this the big brain is this big brain
guy
[Music]
it just pushed in on his eyes
holy
nick you want to go next
i'll go next sure
all right everybody close their eyes
everybody close your eyes
[Applause]
that's so good
what the heck oh
in your childhood memory is that the kai
from toy story the toy collector oh yeah
[Laughter]
it's right up there on the surface for
me
saw that movie about like 50 times in
the last six months
[Music]
that was that connie though
that's kaneda from akira
wow
so that is simpson's character
it's the last airbender yes
what
when you blow your eyes you can actually
see it
[Laughter]
skinny shrimp skinny shrimp
so you put shrimp nick in and then you
got like a real
shrimp nick
[Music]
here's a respectful young man fix the
teeth fix the eyes
i'm very pleased with this shrimp nick i
think we can only improve though there
you have it
[Music]
[Applause]
great job computer
until ai can successfully make me a
human face out of a shrimp face i won't
be happy so if anyone can do that for me
leave a imgur link down in the comment
section below if you guys would like to
figure out how to do this on your own
stay tuned i will do a little tutorial
starting now
hi welcome to niko's tutorial on how to
make cool photo real versions of video
game characters first things first i
have a link in the description below
click that link it's gonna pop open this
collab notebook and then or go to file
save a copy in your drive now you're
gonna see a bunch of these cells and
play buttons next to them and basically
you're gonna go through one by one to go
through this so first we're going to hit
play on the e4e setup run once only it's
going to take about five minutes a few
moments later after that's done a folder
called encoder for editing is going to
appear grab your image that you want to
make a photo real version out of and
drag it into your folder encoder for
editing then under input image you can
type in the name of your image exactly
it's case sensitive so make sure you
match the name exactly including
uppercases lowercases
12 seconds later next up
make sure you don't run it rolled out
make sure you collapse it one minute 37
seconds later there it goes it has the
face here and it shows you a side by
side right here and that's step one you
have your photo reel face
congratulations let's say you wanted to
be high res a style clip set up run once
only you have to run this
let it install
and your final step will be to run the
style clip body which will give you the
high res image
and that's it it's finished and here's
my high res face
that's all you need to do to make photo
real faces out of video game faces now
if you want to do another image you
don't actually have to go through this
huge process anymore it's a lot faster
say i want to do agent 47
copy that into the folder i don't have
to run e4e setup only run that once i've
already ran it instead i'm just going to
tell it i have a new picture agent
47.jpg
hit play don't forget to do that
otherwise it doesn't know that we
changed that we run e4 completion hit
play on that don't run anything that
says run once only you've already run it
you hit play on your style clip body and
that's it
i'd love to see some of your creations
go ahead and share them either on our
subreddit or on instagram using the
hashtag
corridorai face also if you want to know
who put together this collab notebook we
have their credits in the description of
this video there's a lot of names i'm
not very good at pronouncing them so
i'll just leave it there but thank you
for making this cloud notebook and to
all the other people out there who make
open source projects and put them up on
github for other people to experiment
with thank you for sharing knowledge it
helps all of us quite a bit makes the
world a better place